I'm been it's very nice to meet you you
have a lovely daughter I hope you liked
the tattoo oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] it is probably something you'd see
tattooed on someone's inner lip perhaps
no other tattoo is as easily hidden as
this one so what type of person gets an
inner lip tattoo and why do they get it
I got my lip tattoo the day after I
turned 18 I'm obsessed with the Beatles
I thought I was clever when I was 17
it's kind of spontaneous just kind of my
attitude at the time I think like [ __ ]
it you know to me the under the lip
tattoo is just a test run for future
tattoos they're just they're funny if
you want to get a tattoo but you don't
want anyone to see it get a looked at I
have a seed my name is Casey I'm 20
years old and I've been really wanting
an inner lip tattoo lately this is Casey
a college student and tattoo virgin she
really wants an inner lip tattoo because
she can hide it from her mom yikes
and I'm gonna join her every step of the
way and this is Zoe Taylor owner of the
Warren tattoo shop in West Hollywood
she's an incredible tattoo artist and
all-around badass when I think inner lip
tattoo I think joke I think [ __ ] you or
[ __ ] me or [ __ ] my mat like weird it's
always like really Rocking I think
people feel a little more free to be
ballsy when they're doing something in
that area rather than almost any other
area the lip is one of the most hidden
locations on the body if not the most I
guess it would only be you and your
dentist who really sees this thing yeah
exactly it's never gonna be like oh [ __ ]
edition according to the book in
tattooing the inner lip originated in
Western culture and these tattoos are
usually jokes or expletives however
other oral tattoos have a longer history
people in Hawaii and India have been
tattooing their tongues for centuries
even today these tattoos are part of the
cultural zeitgeist is to film black
panther inspired superfans to go out and
get their own as for the tattoo process
it's a mucous membrane's there's mucus
coming out through the stencil while I'm
trying to do it so you have to be really
quick and it's a really really bloody
skin so it's just it doesn't behave like
any other place you attach you so do you
get submissions and you're like no
thanks it's not really my thing they're
kind of a pain in the butt and if I
don't have to deal with him I don't are
you willing to make an exception today
and give us someone a lip tattoo
yes [ __ ] it 40
today Casey is getting her first tattoo
and it happens to be on her inner lip so
I'm heading over to the Kappa Delta
house at UCLA to find out what it is
nice place you got here
thank you is it yours Casey show me
around the sorority house I tried to
impress everyone by playing the piano
then she introduced me to one of her
sisters and friends Erica this is out of
character for her to want a tattoo when
it's really cool but - it gets so funny
and also totally random he's also like a
total sweetheart likes got a nursing
school definitely not something you
would like imagine what are you getting
originally I wanted to get Kyoto which I
searched online means bucket into valise
but I've been leaning maybe more towards
love and lung which means essentially
it's an expression like - be brave be
strong okay fight on whoo yeah I mean I
feel like the videos gonna make this a
lot worse like if you just get a tattoo
when your parents are never find out but
now yeah a lot of things happening Kasey
definitely seemed a little anxious about
the prospect of her parents finding out
so I asked her a little more about what
do you want this tattoo to mean to you I
don't know I think I do risky things
when I feel like things are kind of
unstable this past summer has been the
hardest Sara I've had to deal with yet
my grandfather got really sick and fell
into a coma my mom ended up by a
last-minute plane ticket to the
Philippines and a couple hours later he
passed everything just started clashing
and closing in on me it's really easy to
be in a big school across the country to
feel really small it kind of just
connect me in some way back home does
anyone in your family have tattoos no
you're the first I'm the first what do
you imagine your mom's reaction would be
my mom does even like makeup she doesn't
like anything on my face so having a
tattoo on my face well it's like under
your face it's you know
you'd hate it Casey's mom please don't
hate me I'm so sorry but it's time for
her to spread her wings and fly we
hopped in the car and hit the road back
over to Warren but first a little rape
music do you know anything about how
long they last in my experience they
don't seem to be like a gradually fading
thing I mean I was under the impression
that they disappeared after like five
years I have not found that to be true
you've known it to be that they last
like permanently I've known people for
you know 15 years is still the same
looking lip tattoo and it hasn't changed
so like does that change your way of
thinking about this at all are you
hoping it was temporary
it doesn't really hit me yet this is
gonna happen so do you want this to stay
or do you want it to disappear after
five years it's like I'm out it's
totally up to you
I'm okay with that all right we're all
good yeah submit okay
submit Wow ell a BA
and then a space and then la ng
sir
hold it like at the edges
[Music]
there's no turning back after this point
you sure
[Music]
10 being the most painful how painful is
it right now 7 6 or 7
[Music]
are we done
yeah I walk in here like 30 seconds last
uh-huh
are you ready to see your first ink yeah
I want to see it go ahead
oh my gosh you're kidding me
[Music]
yeah this is exactly what I wanted it
was awesome seeing how pumped Kacey was
about her first ink she loved it so much
actually that she did something none of
us suspected gonna show your mom oh yeah
no I love it I don't care what she
thinks at this point you don't maybe
later but I've just on a rush right now
yeah mama what's up what are you doing
mama oh not much
yeah I've just been studying all day but
I want to show you something okay
okay ready look
you it says live on long fun long it's a
lot of words yeah that's so two words
mama it's hidden only me and you can see
no I know laughs like that
hello I'm partly responsible for this no
this is the artist mama hello it's
person it's well done I wanna hug you
okay so now I can get more yeah oh I
love you very very much
she's so sweet I'm so blown away about
how she reacted me too yeah at the end
of the day I think my mom always like
trusts my judgment on things yeah
whether it's a first foray into tattoos
a spontaneous moment with friends or
something deeper at the end of the day
like all tattoos it is what you make it
in other words bucket
[Music]